but you only Hornby's founder of the
advertising agency and partnership which
is part of the wpp family now Johnny you
call for a boycott last week of sorts
you fairly encouraged bolts been
happening so far well it certainly
didn't go unheeded yes we you know we
said last week that we'd probably been
sitting on too many panels too many
conferences asking the big platforms to
come to the party and it's new it's not
just the big platforms to be fair to to
map Brittain I think it's the whole
industry that needs to to come together
but i think the platforms have been
slower than everyone has wanted and as
Martin Sorrell just said on that report
you know that they're not without the
resources to be able to do something
about this and I think there is you know
there's a number of levels to this
argument look at level number one you
know are you a publisher or are you a
platform is it okay to publish the kind
of content that we've just seen in your
is it okay for them to do that I would
certainly say it isn't but as somebody
who then works in the marketing services
advertising business is it okay once you
publish that content to make it
advertising enabled so allow advertisers
to place their advertising unwittingly
into though into that content and again
I think we'd say no it isn't and it's a
problem that outside of Google and
Facebook the advertising industry media
industry has been able to solve to a
certain extent to a large extent using
third-party ad verification software
that checks the content before it places
the advertising next to it and up until
very recently up until this morning
Facebook and Google have been too slow
to allow us to use those software they
just don't want it to they why not I
think there's a number of reasons you
know I mean if you were being cynical
you might say they're making they've
been making a lot of money you know if
you've got a plethora of content and you
enable the whole lot you take old money
then you're in a very good position now
let's be a bit fairer to Matt Brittin
and some of his colleagues they have
recognized and he's recognized this
morning that they need to tighten this
up but he's talking about using controls
their his controls not our controls we
want to use third party controls
universally in facebook and in Google
not their controls we don't want them
marking their own homework both from a
brand safety point of view to make sure
that our
advertising isn't appearing in the
places you've just shown but also so
that we can mark their homework in terms
of how many people actually saw the
content because we're seeing far too
much of where we're finding Facebook for
example admitting that may be only half
the amount of people had been viewing
their videos because they're telling us
who's viewing it no one tells you no
Indian King live show does not tell the
advertisers how many people are watching
it go check it out and yeah yeah quite
why are we giving Google in particular
such a hard time when Facebook appeared
to be up to this as well I mean I think
we're giving them both a hard time I
think Facebook got their own particular
hard time a couple of years ago with the
Sun expose on on the hate that was found
there and they've made significant move
since but they're still marking their
homework in lots of respects and even
some of the verifiers they're allowing
in there saying you have to use our data
to verify no we want to come completely
inside the inside those walls now their
excuse will be the personal data of
facebook users that is you know that
they shouldn't allow others to come into
but I think it's easily within the width
of these organizations to allow these
software verification tools to come in
without infringing on the pond upon the
personal rights of the individuals all
right Johnny horn but we've got to leave
it there good to see thanks for coming
in